welcome to world stories i'm sumi
somaskanda with your international
reporters magazine on this week's
edition we uncork croatia's best wines
we learn about bangladesh's tradition of
bamboo furniture and we're serving up
caterpillar fungus you don't want to
miss that
but first brazil is a country of
incredible contrasts it's home to the
amazon rainforest but also vast urban
sprawl
tens of millions live in metropolises
like sao paulo and rio de janeiro and
space is at a premium especially green
space
in the city of bel horizonte we meet one
woman who's turned the concrete jungle
around her into a rich garden of herbs
to use and to sell we also traveled to
new york to see how one restaurant has
turned a former construction site into
an award-winning urban garden ready
minis tv reporters carlos augusto suarez
and gail zotero show us more
many people dream of waking up
opening the window
and looking straight into their own
cottage garden
but just because you live in an
apartment
it doesn't mean that dream is out of
reach
instead of traditional garden plots you
can grow herbs and even vegetables in
flower pots and other containers
they all bring new life into this
concrete
inspired by this new trend andrea veloso
has become a self-employed urban
gardener and helps her customers
reconnect with the natural world
then he can tell from the label which
one is mint
and doesn't end up making himself tea
with chives by mistake
these mini gardens are tailored to each
customer's wishes they vary in size and
cost between 12 and 15 reals some 4 to
18 euros
this mint plant here was as small as
this one originally
and then
yes
you can have a small garden or several
small gardens
this container is just right for a
window ledge
and this is arugula or rocket which
tastes really good in salad pasta dishes
and in sandwiches
you have a lot of customers would you
say that urban gardening is growing in
popularity
yes definitely
people are yearning for more healthy
lives that are more in tune with nature
these gardens aren't just healthy
they're also pleasing to the eyes
grew up in the country and her parents
had a garden
but the tough urban life in pero
horizonte one of brazil's largest cities
has not diminished her craving for
nature
our passion was
it's a passion you come home and you can
smell the plants and it makes you feel
hungry
so you can just pick a little yes
it tastes so good
and it helps
when the children make themselves a
sandwich they can pick the fresh herbs
and use them to flavor their food it's
really practical
the plants make me want to cook and they
make me so happy i really like that
for maria home gardening is a simple
pastime with great rewards
but brazil isn't the only country
rediscovering its green roots
urban gardens are blooming throughout
the world
here in manhattan i'm about to see how a
restaurant has created its own urban
garden let's go
the river park restaurant is here and
its award-winning garden right next to
it
originally this property was a
development site but when the
construction work stalled the
restaurant's owners asked to use the
space
the garden is now a beacon project in
new york where land prices are among the
highest in the world the gardens
creators needed to come up with some
creative solutions to make use of what
little space was available
they decided to grow the plants in
plastic containers like this one
the 7400 pots are actually recycled milk
containers
but with good fertilizer and a green
thumb the double stacked milk crates can
provide a good home for fruits and
vegetables
more than 180 different types of plants
grow here but only one gardener is
needed to keep an eye on the farm
the project manager says that the garden
produces enough fresh fruit and
vegetables for the restaurant
and the project has even become a
tourist attraction
with cities around the world becoming
more crowded projects like the river
park farm could be a model for future
urban spaces
now to a crisis gripping large parts of
sudan
weeks of heavy rains in the north
african country have triggered severe
flooding and nearly 600 thousand people
have been affected the area around the
capital khartoum has been hit hard
especially rural villages and towns that
have been cut off from aid sudan's flood
task force is doing its best to help but
they face an uphill battle many roads
are submerged and there are growing
concerns that mosquitoes and tainted
drinking water could spread disease
throughout the region
nbc reporter mohammad osman went to the
flood-hit state of white nile and sent
us this report
we've traveled about 300 kilometers
south from the sudanese capital cartoon
into the heart of the white nile state
heavy rainfall and flash flooding have
destroyed or damaged many towns and
villages making orientation difficult
you need a lot of patience and a guide
to help you find your way around
the flooding damaged homes and displaced
families throughout the region
flood waters have undermined the
foundations of this school making it
dangerous for children to attend class
the teachers have been forced to start
holding lectures in the schoolyard to
keep the children safe
six classrooms have been completely
ruined and we dare not go into them
we prefer to stay outside
four classrooms are still okay
how much damage is there
you can find damage throughout this
region
the school the health center all of the
houses that you see here everything is
submerged
there's water surrounding the entire
village
and the sky is still overcast
flood flood waters inundated this
village the environmental and health
risks are huge
fresh water is hard to come by and pools
of stagnant water provide ideal breeding
grounds for disease-carrying mosquitoes
survival has become very difficult
local people try to carry on as best
they can
but a local midwife says the flood
waters are making it impossible for some
of her patients to get medical treatment
i recently had a case with complications
the woman was three months pregnant and
was bleeding heavily but the roads to
the hospital were blocked and she lost
her child i did my best to care for her
but my means are limited
the roads were blocked because of
flooding
yes all the roads were blocked it was
nighttime and there was nowhere we could
take her
many other villages in the region are
still isolated due to the flooding
complicating the government's relief
efforts with no sign that flood waters
will recede in the near future sudan's
flood task force is refocusing their
efforts to help those hardest hit by the
disaster
we can say that everything is under
control
because more villages and areas are
being affected by the heavy rainfall
as well as by the flooding
the skies in sudan's white nile state
are still thick with rain clouds and
local authorities have predicted more
heavy rains could strike the area in the
coming days
residents are doing their best to
prepare shoring up their houses or
demolishing structures that are unsafe
thanks to nbc for that report
well when we think of great wine a few
places come to mind france italy
california for example but croatia is
slowly creeping its way onto that short
list it's been producing high quality
wine for more than 2 000 years and
families big and small are carrying on
the tradition in our next story hrt's
stella stepp takes us on a journey to
croatia's wine country enjoy
fertile black soil and rolling hills of
croatia's podonavia wine region a
picturesque destination on the banks of
the danube steeped in centuries of
tradition
croatia's wine roads stretch from
bottina in the north to illoc in the
south
the carpanthian basin lies in the heart
of croatia's western wine region
it's home to canajevi vinogradi
a small agricultural community featuring
the country's oldest vineyard
which was founded in the 16th century
here in this cellar with over 1200
square meters of floor space we have 300
000 liters of wine
we also have a vintage collection
featuring over 7 000 bottles where the
oldest one is from 1949. we take
winemaking seriously in this region
in contrast to canada v vinogradi's
traditional charm the vina bellia is one
of the world's most modern wineries
construction finished on the massive
facility located near bonovo bordeaux
last year
we need to start processing as soon as
possible since we harvest manually
throughout the 583 hectares so the
grapes are brought here these tanks can
hold 8 million liters
wine making may be big business for some
but many families are rediscovering the
art of hawaiian making at home like here
in sousa
i've taken this over from my father who
was a good winemaker he sold his wine at
the end and on the doorstep like this
and we're continuing this tradition
near souza is mayavats where surduce or
narrow canyon-like roads are a popular
destination for tourists
and wine lovers on the hunt for
something out of the ordinary would do
well with a visit to erdut to see a
winemaking piece of art
here we have a barrel made of slavonian
oak with a capacity of 75 000 liters
it was made in 1990 by d ik giordinovac
and it's still in use today
throughout the danube basin
many small villages are expanding their
offerings for tourists
in addition to good wine we also offer
accommodation we have 10 double rooms
from roman times through the middle ages
and up to the present day croatia's
podunavia wine region has preserved the
tradition of handcrafted wine on the
banks of the danube
onwards now to bangladesh to a region
called movibazar with its warm climate
and rich soil the area exports fruits
and teas and bamboo it's a popular
building material in bangladesh because
it's both sturdy and sleek and it's used
in all sorts of handicrafts in our next
story etv's sakawat liton introduces us
to a man who's dedicated his life to
making bamboo furniture his products
have grown so popular they're in demand
around the country here's more
bamboo grows widely in bangladesh
and it's used for many different
purposes in rural regions from thatching
roofs to making baskets
amir hosain siraj decided to start
making bamboo furniture using
traditional techniques and it's become
his passion
his business has really taken off the
furniture is proving popular in his
native mulivi bazaar region and in other
parts of bangladesh as well
i mean
i wanted to do something different
in 2001 i started making furniture for
my apartment
a few people saw the furniture and began
to ask me if i would make them
so i turned it into a business
worked in a plant nursery
then he started making bamboo furniture
based on his own designs
then he started supplying furniture for
weddings and other social occasions
he has really expanded his contacts
district adorned with decorative bamboo
objects as well as furniture he's made
we are very proud of him
he has set up a new kind of craft
business
he is using bamboo to manufacture
furniture it's helping the development
of our country
right from the outset people were
attracted to the furniture amir made
this encouraged him to make the leap to
manufacturing it commercially
next door to the store is the workshop
where the furniture is made
siraj makes beds sofas chairs dining
tables and side tables trays and various
decorative objects
we place the bamboo rods in a water tank
for 72 hours and leave it to dry in the
shade for 15 days
after that it's ready to use
the bamboo furniture isn't just
attractive it's also durable
many bangladeshis are choosing to
furnish their homes with it
it's a growing interior design trend
there's a big demand for this type of
furniture
bangladeshis living abroad have told me
that it would sell in indonesia or
malaysia
i hope our country can export it
by using bamboo for the manufacturer
furniture we can reduce the pressure on
our precious wood supplies
bamboo is readily available in our
country if the government takes the
initiative bamboo furniture will become
popular in the entire country
amir siraj has strived to improve the
quality of his bamboo products it was a
long process but he's convinced he's
found the right technique to allow him
to offer his customers high quality and
sturdy handmade furniture
cane furniture is usually guaranteed to
last up to 20 years
but we have a 40-year guarantee
mr
didn't have the opportunity to publicize
his products via the mass media
despite that people come to him and
order furniture
and then get back in touch later
if the
both environmentally friendly and
aesthetically pleasing amer hosain
siraj's bamboo furniture is a
sustainable choice for interior
decoration
and finally to a culinary delicacy
that's stirring up controversy in china
it all centers around a rare caterpillar
fungus that's a highly potent substance
in chinese medicine it's believed to be
a cure for many diseases
it may not look like much a small brown
twig with a dried worm on the end but
the fungus is in such high demand with
both traditional chinese doctors and
cooks alike that it's worth more than
gold reporter anya koch explains
the tibetan plateau at 3 000 meters
above sea level is home to a fungus
that's taking the world by storm
in tibetan it's known as the yatsa yards
which means summer grass winter worm but
it's actually a fungus that invades the
caterpillar of the ghost moth and
digests it from within
in the winter it buries itself in the
ground and in spring it will grow these
grass-like parts because it's been
affected by the fungus
when peasants dig it they look for the
grassy part
the worm is already dead because the
fungus has killed it
the fungus grows out of the head of the
caterpillar host looking like a brown
twig emerging from the ground harvesting
it takes a keen eye
the dried fruiting bodies are then
bundled together and sold
we separate the damaged parts because
the broken ones are cheaper the whole
winds fetch higher prices
a kilo of caterpillar fungus costs
anywhere from five to nearly 45 000
euros making it many times more
expensive than the truffle
while the caterpillar fungus may not
look very appetizing it's in great
demand
a lot of my friends like to eat
caterpillar fungus
they usually give it to their parents
their elders and also to the children
but what makes the fungus so popular
pan chaoshi is an expert in traditional
chinese medicine he says the fungus is a
remedy for a variety of ailments
it's good for sexual dysfunctions and
for coughing up blood
the fungi are also a popular ingredient
in chinese cooking
served with beef tongue it's a delicacy
that's highly prized by wealthy chinese
serving caterpillar fungi is also a
status symbol among urban chinese
others are stockpiling the fungus as an
investment after all it's more expensive
now than gold
for many local families the fungus
harvest means welcome extra income but
as the fungus's value grows so do the
number of disputes that end in violence
and some professional fungi gatherers
have given up the harvest because of the
damage that's being done to the
environment
the pollution is very serious
now in my hometown the water is almost
dried up
the grass is dying also dry
this is very bad for us in the tibetan
areas and our lama our living buddha
told us never to dig out the fungus even
if we have nothing to eat for three days
in a row and we're starving
has found a new job
but as long as prices for the
caterpillar fungus soar
the harvest will continue
sounds delicious well that's all for
this week's edition of world stories for
all of us here and our partner stations
around the world we want to thank you
for watching you can see this episode
again and many more at our website
that's dw.de
world stories before you go we'll leave
you with this week's picks of the world
enjoy and see you next time
you